Prof: All right,
ladies and gentlemen.
Let's get started.
We are going to continue our
discussion of melody,
and last Thursday we were
talking about melody in terms of
scales: major scales,
minor scales, chromatic scales.
Then we went on to talk a
little bit about what it is in a
melody that makes us feel the
way we do about that particular
melody--
the major and minor quality of
them,
and the fact that that quality
shows up rather early on in the
scale,
the third step of the scale.
Then we talked about conjunct
melodies,
and disjunct melodies,
and we ended up talking about
Beethoven's Ode to Joy,
which he incorporated in the
last movement of his last
symphony,
Symphony no. nine.
And we said that that had a
particular quality of phrase
construction--antecedent and
consequent phrase structure.
>
Opening it up--<<plays
piano>>
--and closing it back down.
And I was thinking over the
weekend of all the pieces that
operate that way.
>
Antecedent--<<plays
piano>>
--consequent.
And then it goes on with an
extension the way Beethoven went
on with an extension--
>
Antecedent-- <<plays
piano>>
--consequent.
I was a thinking of a piece of
Mozart--<<plays
piano>>
Was that really Mozart?
Well let's listen here to just
a little bit of what that really
is.
Okay.
>
All right.
That's enough of that.
Dumb pet trick.
All I did was take the theme of
the Macarena and strip
away all the rhythmic stuff
underneath,
and put an eighteenth-century
Alberti bass with it,
that Mozart would have
used--<<plays
piano>>
--and so on.
But the point here is that even
the Macarena is using
this antecedent and consequent
phrase structure--something as
basic as that.
So it's sort of endemic to how
melodies are constructed.
Now I was thinking--and I
always like to try to come up
with new, however albeit
lame-brained,
ideas--for teaching this class.
Supposing I got a student up
here, I mean melody--what makes
a melody beautiful?
What makes a great melody?
Anybody know?
Well, if you do,
let me know,
because I don't know,
and nobody really knows.
It's sort of like the
definition of pornography:
you know it when you see it,
or you know it when you hear
it.
So in pursuit of this,
I was trying to think,
"Well, maybe I'll have a
student come up and try to craft
a melody right here on the
spot."
And I supposed we could play
with that,
but then I said,
"That's probably not a
good idea,
because a) No student would
really want to do this,
and b) It would probably take
too long to work through all the
aspects of it."
So what I did--and this was
about four o'clock yesterday
afternoon--and I thought,
"Craig,
you think up a melody."
So I started thinking up a
melody, and I hope I can
remember how it went.
>
Something like that.
So what would you give me as a
grade for that melody?
Come on, now.
Daniel, what do I get for that
melody?
B minus? C plus?
Student:  B..
Prof: B?
Well, this is the days of grade
inflation.
I've been inflated up to a B.
It was kind of C, C minus.
It wasn't particularly inspired.
But in crafting that,
it made me think of "Why
do I do this at this particular
point and not that?"
Well, there are certain
confines that we're operating
with.
We've got to be in a scale.
>
Certain kinds of
phrases--<<plays
piano>>
--something ending like that in
a piece that's going to end
here--<<plays
piano>>
--tells me that's got to be in
the middle;
that can't come at the end.
So there's a syntax here also.
We've talked about that before,
that musical phrases have to
come in a particular order for
them to make sense.
So instead of working with my
lame-brained melody,
let's work with a great one.
We're going to work a melody by
Giacomo Puccini here,
and you can see his name on the
board up there,
and get a sense of the melody
in question.
It's an aria-- and we'll talk
about what an aria is later--but
it's an aria from his opera
Gianni Schicchi.
Now, that's not a well-known
opera by Puccini;
can anybody tell me the name of
a better-known opera by Puccini?
Student:  Tosca..
Prof: Tosca,
yes.
Student:  Madame
Butterfly..
Prof: Madame
Butterfly.
You haven't hit the most
obvious yet--La
Bohème,
for example.
Rent was based on La
Bohème.
So he has written a lot of
well-known operas;
this happens to be a
lesser-known opera.
But it has one sort of
drop-dead beautiful melody in
the thing,
"O mio babbino caro,"
where a young lady is trying,
in effect, to con some money
out of her father.
And it's an odd thing,
this thing so beautiful--trying
to separate her father from
money is an odd thought.
And it occurs rather early on
in the opera,
too.
And dramatically,
it's not of any particular
significance.
It just happens to be an
absolutely gorgeous melody that
you've all heard many,
many times.
One day--you'll recognize it as
soon as I start to play it--one
day I was playing this at home;
my then-thirteen-year-old son
came in and said,
"I know that.
That's beautiful."
I said, "Ah, that's my boy.
He's going to be a music
lover."
"Yes, that's the
background music for Grand
Theft Auto."
"What's Grand Theft
Auto, Chris?"
Well, I found out.
But it shows you that this
particular aria has legs.
It's kind of everywhere.
So let's listen to a little bit
of Puccini's "O mio bambino
caro."
>
Okay, let's pause it right
there.
Let's pause it.
>
What's kind of neat about that,
right, at the outset
there--<<plays
piano>>
What's that?
Why, again, do our spirits soar
at that particular point?
We've got a large leap there.
It's the leap of a--
Student:  An octave.
Prof: Of an octave.
We wouldn't expect you to
recognize that,
but it's interesting to fold
that in, because we were talking
about octaves last time.
So we have this opening phrase,
and it's about to be coupled--
we're going to continue now--
with the next phrase that will
complete the antecedent phrase.
>
So we're sitting here--can you
see the tonic?
That's where we want to go,
that's where we want to go.
So we're going to step right
above the tonic.
So that's the end of the
antecedent phrase,
the opening-up phrase,
but we're not on the tonic.
Okay?
So now we're going to continue,
and you can imagine we're going
to hear some of that same music.
But ultimately,
it's going to come back to the
tonic;
we hadn't gone away from it.
Okay.
>
Starting again.
Here's our octave.
>
Now, something interesting
happened there.
>
Ah, there's our tonic.
We should be back to our tonic.
But that's not exactly what
happened.
>
We went to the tonic melody
note, but underneath he
harmonized it with an unexpected
harmony.
We expected to hear:
>
We got: <<plays
piano>>
So we were deceived there a
little bit.
And musicians call this a
deceptive cadence.
When the whole thing has been
set up to come back to the tonic
with the tonic chord
underneath--<<plays
piano>>
--we get something other than
the tonic chord.
So in music,
we have to kinds of really
broad categories of cadence.
We have this kind of thing
called--<<plays
piano>>
Or: >
--where we come back to the
expected tonic.
We call those authentic
cadences.
We also have another class of,
as mentioned,
deceptive cadences where we do
things such as:
>
Where you're expecting to go:
But we go: <<plays
piano>>
Or we go even more bizarre:
>
Something like that.
You keep the same tonic note in
the melody, but you change the
harmony underneath.
So that's what Puccini has done
here.
>
Instead of going there,
he goes: <<plays
piano>>
--there.
Here is a silly analogy.
One time I was flying into the
city of Minneapolis.
"Fasten your seat belts,
trays up,"
etc., etc., etc.;
we're coming right in there,
you can see the tarmac there
and suddenly the plane goes
"Zoom."
It doesn't land,
it does a barrel roll almost
off to the right,
circles all the way around,
announces there was some piece
of equipment on the landing
strip,
and he was doing a flyover.
In music, you have to do the
same kind of thing.
If a composer has set this up
so that you're expecting to go:
>
And you don't,
you go here-- <<plays
piano>>
We can't end that way.
We just can't end that way.
We need our daily supply of
tonic.
So what we've got to do is a
musical flyover.
He's going to fly all around
this thing again,
and then come back in and this
time land on the tonic.
So let's listen to the flyover:
>
Here's our tonic.
But it's so lovely,
he can't stop.
So he's going to give you a
little reminiscence of the
beginning--
>
There's our octave.
So there's just a little
reminiscence of the beginning,
but again coming back and just
then, of course,
ending on the tonic.
So that's the structure of an
aria by Puccini,
and it is highly structured.
Now I want to talk about
another aria that's structured
in a different way,
and that's by Richard Wagner.
But before we do that,
we need to talk about one other
process in music,
and that has to do with
something called melodic
sequence.
And oddly, students over the
years have had difficulty
understanding and hearing
melodic sequence.
But it's a pretty simple idea.
Melodic sequence is simply the
repetition of a musical motive
at a successively higher or
lower degree of the scale.
So I could take a
motive--anybody want to sing a
motive for me here?
Daniel do you want to sing a
motive?
Give me four notes.
>
So we've set up a descending
melodic sequence.
Now, supposing we did this?
>
That's obviously an ascending
melodic sequence.
So that's what's involved here,
and generally speaking,
going down introduces
relaxation;
going up, perhaps, tension.
All right.
So that's a little bit of the
set up with regard to that.
So now we're going to work
through this--
we'll call it an aria for the
moment--
of Wagner, in which,
rather than structured units,
he's going to continually
evolve new music,
but using a motive that he
presses up continually through
melodic sequence.
So it's a slightly different
process of melodic structure
here.
Richard Wagner--not a very nice
man, needless to say.
But he was a spectacular
composer, and wrote many great
things.
And one of them,
arguably the best that he
wrote, is his opera
Tristan.
Tristan and Isolde,
written in 1865,
as you can see on the board
here.
And we should know about it
because we here at Yale own the
piano on which Wagner wrote
Tristan,
or it was at least involved in
part of Tristan.
Next time you are walking past
DUH over there,
you know, the Health Center,
at seventeen Hillhouse Avenue,
there's a building there,
a rather foreboding looking
building.
Inside is a wonderful
collection of keyboard
instruments.
So go in there and look at the
Bechstein piano,
this German piano,
Bechstein, that Wagner used
when working on Tristan.
So we have the opera,
and we're going to start here
with a little bit of the plot.
It's a story of this English
knight,
Tristan, and this Irish
princess, Isolde,
and it's Tristan's job to go
over to Ireland and pick her up
and deliver her back to Cornwall
where she is supposed to marry
King Mark.
But en route,
they inadvertently consume a
love potion, so she is
passionately in love with him,
and he with her.
So we're going to listen to a
little bit of the overture here
now.
Wagner actually called it a
prelude--that doesn't
matter--opening music here,
to Tristan.
And I have two questions
for you as we listen here.
What instruments are playing?
And what musical process is
Wagner using at this point?
>
Okay, we're going to stop it
there, now.
So what instruments were
playing there in that little
dialogue--the dialogue between
families of instruments?
Strings, and?
Woodwinds.
Okay, alternating back and
forth.
The strings were at the lower
point--<<plays
piano>>
--and the woodwinds would
answer--<<plays
piano>>
--then strings--<<plays
And so on.
So what melodic process were
they using there?
Rising melodic sequence.
All right, it sort of chugged
along until we got
to-->
What's this?
We talked about this before in
regard to Richard Strauss.
That sound?
It's a dissonant sound
resolving to consonant.
So it uses this sequence to
work up to a climax,
hits a dissonance,
resolves it into consonance.
Let's listen to a little bit
further along here in the
prelude.
>
Now he's churning his way up
here through sequence;
each level gets higher and
higher in the violins.
>
Okay, let's stop it there.
And you heard the trumpets come
in there--<<plays
piano>>
--with that chromatic figure,
almost kind of like a snake
rising through it.
So it's not only the rising
melodic sequence.
This is highly chromatic music,
and that also produces tension.
How do you make love in music?
Well, you've got rising dynamic
volume, we've got rising
sequence that works up to a
climax where there is dissonance
and then release.
So if I'm using rather
suggestive language here,
it's done intentionally.
This ain't Mary Poppins
or The Sound of Music or
Snow White and the Seven
Dwarfs;
this is the passionate story of
Tristan and Isolde:
lust, desire,
carnal knowledge,
that sort of thing.
And how does Wagner give you
this sense?
How does he communicate this?
Well there's this idea of
continually rising sequence that
then hits this climax with a
dissonant, almost painful
dissonance, and then the
resolution;
the music duplicating in an odd
way life's processes.
The climax of the opera,
the real climax,
however, really doesn't come
until about three hours into it,
at the end.
Now we have Tristan dying of a
mortal wound.
Isolde is cradling him in her
arms.
And she sings an aria.
We'll call it an aria;
Wagner called it a different
name, it's called the
"Liebestod."
She's singing about her vision
of their life in the hereafter,
in the world beyond,
in the celestial realm.
And so it's called a
"love-death,"
a Liebestod here,
and it's typical,
I suppose, of the conventions
of the Romantic period.
This is the nineteenth century;
this is romance,
Tristan and Isolde.
So we're going to pick this up
about halfway through the
Liebestod of Isolde,
and once again we will hear
these little snippets,
these motives.
<<noise from
outside>>
I don't have absolute pitch.
When you're really annoyed with
things in life,
you can sometimes at least have
some fun, enjoy it somehow,
by trying to figure out what
key it's in.
That was a pipe in F we were
listening to,
a rather unresonant pipe in F.
Okay, so let's go back to the
midpoint of the Liebestod
here, and we're going to
hear these little snippets.
This is not antecedent and
consequent;
this is a motive being pushed
higher and higher each time to a
climax.
Here we go:
>
Okay, we're going to pause it
there just for a second.
It's glorious.
It's a glorious sound.
And isn't it nice to have our
audio system working properly
again?
This is really the first day
that it's worked properly.
So it sounds wonderful.
It's glorious.
It's a glorious climax that
Wagner has been working for--for
three hours here,
that we've got,
that we've arrived at.
But now he's going to turn
everything around.
The entire sentiment is going
to change.
And I think we should be able
enumerate here,
maybe as many as four different
ways in which Wagner does turn
our emotions one hundred eighty
degrees at this point.
So we're going to go back,
and we're going to listen to
the climax again,
and then we're going to listen
to how the music changes.
And I want you to,
as you sit there,
to think about,
"What's he doing
here?"
You're the composer;
how do you make something go
from sort of cradle in your arms
to vision of the world beyond.
So think about dynamics,
think about tempo,
think about these sequences,
consonance and dissonance,
etc., etc., etc.
Okay, here we go.<<plays
music>>
Well, I hope you liked that.
Really gorgeous.
So get me started here.
What did you hear there?
How did he slow down this
entire train?
Yes?
Student:  It got softer.
Prof: So the whole thing
got softer.
So we're going to take the
basics first.
And that would be number one on
my list--the whole thing got
softer.
What else happened?
Not only soft--although the
voice ended up rather high--what
are the last sounds we heard?
>
It also ended lower.
And we talked about high and
low intention,
that sort of thing,
before.
Softer, maybe lower generally
in terms of the tessitura,
or the range.
What else?
Chris?
Student:  The tempo got
slower.
Prof: Yes.
There were some points that the
tempo got slower.
And we'll talk about that in
just a minute if we hit on
anything else here.
Anything else?
Elizabeth?
Student:  Fewer
instruments?
Prof: Well,
they weren't playing as loud.
They weren't quite as obvious.
I'm not sure that there were
fewer instruments.
My guess is,
if I were to look at that
score, it would be huge and
everybody would still be
playing.
It's just that it sounded fewer
because they were playing more
quietly.
What about--Roger?
Student:
>
Prof: Yes,
he used the dissonance.
For example,
we had that snake idea,
that snake in the Garden of
Eden: <<plays
piano>>
He was writhing around there,
but then he took it up two more
degrees and folded it in to a
consonance, so it was all very
consonant at the end.
What about the sequence?
It was a--<<plays
piano>>
It was rising,
rising, rising,
but here at the end it started
doing: <<plays
piano>>
It's just repeating the same
pitches over and over and over
again.
He took that out of the
equation, too.
He backed out of this idea,
of the sequence.
It's static at this point.
We have stasis,
we have arrival,
stability.
What was the one thing that we
haven't mentioned in terms of
the tonality here?
>
There at the end--what is that
last sound?
Very strongly, the tonic.
>
That's the way it ended.
There was one other thing that
was kind of cool here.
I'm trying to think of the
exact-- <<plays
piano>>
We had that kind of sound--
>
Supposing I went--
Does this have any resonance to
you?
>
Where are you,
if you hear this sound?
Hmm?
>
Maybe in Yale Commencement
where we sing hymns or at church
or something like that.
But we would call that an
Amen--an Amen cadence.
What does that bring to the--it
sort of brings the divine
benediction here.
Now, the nineteenth century,
life is more
painful--<<plays
piano>>
But you have a sense here at
the end that they're living a
blessed existence in heaven;
it may be because Wagner has
folded in, sort of subliminally,
below the surface,
this cadence.
We have deceptive cadences
here, and we have another kind
of cadence called an Amen
cadence that brings an
additional resonance--
an additional symbolism to the
conclusion.
So it's a wonderful piece of
music,
and maybe--I think we have
time--let's listen to just the
last few seconds of that again,
because it recaps some of the
points we've been making.
>
Here's the snake going away.
Here's the consonance.
Okay, good.
So that's the Liebestod
of Richard Wagner.
Questions about that?
Thoughts about that?
Comments about that?
All right, if not,
let's go on to talk about
Mozart, a little bit more about
Mozart.
We're going to hear another
aria by Mozart,
and this one does something a
little bit different than--
well, it's a kind of
combination of what we've just
studied here.
We've got a highly structured
aria by Mozart;
yet at the same time,
we're going to see an example
of rising melodic sequence in
it.
And we have a guest artist
today: Lauren Libaw.
So Lauren, come on up.
Some of you know Lauren;
she's in Davenport College.
And I've known her for years
now because she is a music
major,
and I've seen her sing in lots
of different productions--
in the School of Music's
Orpheus and the
Underworld a year or so ago.
So, Lauren, I know that you've
sung with the Los Angeles Opera,
and I remember that you sang
with David Stern in Brussels--
was it Brussels or Paris or
both?
Student:  Both.
Prof: Both.
Probably at Le
Châtelet in Paris?
Yes.
The Châtelet
Theater, the big metro change.
So she's a very experienced
singer, and a very,
very good singer.
But tell us,
Lauren, what do you want to do
with this?
Here you are at Yale;
you could become an opera
singer or you could go to law
school and work for Skadden Arps
in New York or Los Angeles or
whatever you want to do.
What are you going to do with
all this?
Student:  I would like
to pursue a career in opera;
law school isn't for me,
although I do like to argue.
Sorry, parents.
Prof: So this year,
if you're a senior,
are you going to take a year
off?
Or are you going to apply
directly to graduate schools in
voice?
And where are you going to
apply if you're feeling to do
that?
Student:  Actually,
I'm going to go back to work
with David Stern in Paris.
Prof: So you're in that
already?
Student:  Yes.
He very kindly has asked me.
Prof: David Stern was a
Yale undergraduate.
He is the son--and he was the
nicest boy--the son of who?
Of whom?
Stern? Does that ring a bell?
Isaac Stern,
the world-famous--one of the
greatest violinists of the
twentieth century.
So David was an undergraduate
here, graduated probably fifteen
or so years ago,
went on to a career in music as
a conductor, mostly in Europe.
Student:  I think he
told me that he was a TA for
this class.
Prof: He would come in
from time to time,
and we would do things in here.
As an undergraduate,
he was not a TA--but then he
was a conductor for the YSO for
a couple of years.
So he would come in from time
to time and we would do
different things.
So Lauren, as I've mentioned,
is a very experienced singer,
and we're going to do a little
aria here out of Mozart's
Figaro,
his opera The Marriage of
1786, called "Voi che
sapete."
So Lauren, can you tell us
something about this aria?
Who's singing it?
Student:  This aria is
sung by Cherubino,
who is a young boy,
actually–I'm wearing
pants for the purpose.
It's called a "trouser
role" for that reason.
It's sung by a woman.
Prof: Why do they do
that?
Did the weird opera people like
transvestites or something?
There are other roles like
this--it's just kind a
convention in opera.
Student:  He is a young
boy--so maybe the high voice--
Prof: He's an
adolescent, fourteen,
and what's he experiencing
here?
Student:  First love or
first lust.
Prof: He's not sure.
Student:  He's not sure.
He's singing to the Countess,
with whom he's in love--with a
little help from Susanna.
Prof: Susanna?
So he thinks he's in love with
the countess,
but maybe it's Susanna or maybe
it's Barbarina,
or maybe it's that broomstick
over there.
It's really hard to know
exactly whom he's in love with
at age fourteen.
That's the confusion here.
So if there's a certain
palpitation from time to time,
it's intentional here--and a
certain sense of being
flustered,
almost--agitated or
flustered--you're uncertain
about what these things are.
We're going to have Lauren sing
all of this for us.
But in order to have this be
something other than just a
performance, I'd like to work
through different pedagogical
issues here.
So let's talk about that just
for a second.
Now, at the outset of this,
and you guys have your sheets
out there;
there's a sheet on the music
stand back there--you've got a
sheet.
So take a look at that.
And we'll see--what do you
see--Marcus?
Right down here in the front
row, what do you see on your
sheet by way of music?
Student:  That it's
broken up into two different
parts.
Three, I guess.
Prof: Three.
And they're labeled
"antecedent"
and "consequent."
So Mozart starts out here with
the antecedent and consequent
phrase structure.
>
That was the antecedent;
here comes consequent.
>
So antecedent/consequent.
Then, interestingly enough,
when the voice comes in,
what does he do,
Lauren?
What does he do there?
You have to sing-- you just
don't duplicate what I did.
Student:  He actually
expands different structure by
adding more material in the
middle.
Prof: So he had an A and
B,
but his mind is such--I mean,
I'd never be able to figure
that out--
he said, "Well,
I can open this whole thing up
and put in some additional
lovely music,
and then close it back down
with my consequent phrase
structure."
So we have that.
Let's listen to how that plays
out.
So we'll just start with where
you come in, Lauren,
with "Voi,"
okay?
<<plays piano while
student sings>>
And then we go on with a series
of phrases, and as you listen to
this, you might count the number
of bars and phrases here.
But generally speaking,
they're all four bars in
length.
Mozart is one of the guys that
puts this whole idea of
structure with melody on the
map.
Structure, symmetry are very
important in his compositions.
And as we proceed here,
the text gets more and more
interesting.
We start talking about feelings
at line five there.
"Sento un
affetto"--how would you
translate, I guess we have a
translator.
Student:  "Sento un
affetto."
"I feel,"--&qu
ot;affetto"
in Italian, that's like
"something."
Prof: Emotion?
Student:  Yes.
Prof: And then sometimes
he is really happy,
and then sometimes he's sort of
despairing.
What's kind of cool,
when we get over to the
despairing idea here on the
piano--<<plays
piano>>
We're here, and we go
to-->
And then he's going to be
burning like a flame and then
freezing to death,
so we get the weird harmonies
out here as he's freezing and
thawing.
So let's hear just a little
bit, maybe with--from there--at
"Sento un affetto"
okay?
<<plays piano while
student sings>>
Okay.
Now we're going to go on to a
little bit later--lovely,
lovely, lovely.
We're going to go on to a
little bit later.
If you can follow on your text
to "Sospiro e gemo senza
voler, palpito e tremo senza
saper" and so on.
What does Mozart do here in
terms of structure?
Student:  A sequence He
repeats the same series of notes
progressively higher,
to illustrate--as you hear the
notes rising--angst--
Prof: Good. Agitation.
So pick it up here at the
B-flat, and I'll try to catch
up.
<<plays music while
student>>
Okay, so notice there,
how as we come to the end of
that, we work up there--it rises
up through the rising melodic
sequence.
We get--Lauren hits that high
note up there,
and then comes off of
it--that's the climax,
the peak of the whole aria--
and then the bass,
what's the bass doing?
It's sort of sneaking back down
to the tonic.
And when we get back to the
tonic, then it comes in.
We're going to pick it up from
there.
Lauren, we're going to sing to
that when we get over there to
>
just hold on "cor"
and we'll ask them a question:
What happened here?
What do we have here?
We'll see if you can hold on
that "cor."
From the "voi."
<<plays piano while
student sings>>
Prof: Nice.
So what did Mozart do there?
What was that?
Student:  Had a
deceptive cadence.
Prof: Had a deceptive
cadence--good,
Marcus scores big today.
We're sitting here on this:
>
We want it to go:
But instead it goes:
>
That's the "cor."
And then we have our flyover:
<<plays piano while
student sings>>
And that's the way it ends.
So you come back to the tonic,
okay?
We've arrived. We've landed.
All right, I think we have time
to do the whole thing now from
beginning to end,
and we'll get our pages in
order.
So, Lauren Libaw singing
"Voi che sapete"
from Mozart's The Marriage
of Figaro.
<<plays piano while
student sings>>
>
Lovely, lovely, lovely.
Aren't we fortunate to have
such talented students here at
Yale?
Okay, well thank you all very
much.
We'll play a little more
Puccini on your way out,
and I hope you enjoy this day
as beautiful as all this music
has been.